huan criquets ayo présidente de l'union
régionale des médecins libéraux de
martin un cri caillou bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors on
l'a vu beaucoup de manifestations contre
les restrictions sanitaires 1 qui se
multipliaient sur l'île le retour du
couvre feu à 21h en raison de
l'aggravation de la situation épidémique
restée vide cristallise de vives
tensions quelle est la situation sur
place
alors bonjour la situation à celle où
est assez catastrophique 1 2200 nouveaux
cas la semaine dernière la situation de
somme sur une île avec des moyens très
comptera donc malheureusement beaucoup
d'inflation avec cette expansion de
l'aco vide 3% faut bien signalé
seulement que 3% des contaminés sont
issus par les voyageurs donc ça veut
bien dire que c'est une vague c'est un
problème de non vaccination de la
population avec une contamination chez
les autochtones donc vraiment il faut
faire un appel que chacun se fasse
vacciner et d'augmenter le seuil de
vaccination qui est dans notre île qui
est catastrophique qui n a même pas 10
7%
donc il faut que les martiniquais
prennent conscience c'est pas une
atteinte à la liberté mais la liberté
commence aussi par celle des autres donc
en tant que soignant nous devons bien
sûr être vaccinés et protéger les autres
et il faut inciter la population à se
faire vacciner d'autant plus que nous
avons à une population âgée une
population fragile avec un taux
d'incidence de comorbidité plus
important avec une prévalence du diabète
10 % en martinique
il faut que chacun se sente responsable
et incite à la vaccination pour protéger
vous avez vu dans le reportage des
risques dongeois de patients vers la
métropole pourquoi parce que nous
n'avons qu'un seul chu et loti à chaud
est en grande souffrance à faire en
grande tension et les patients
actuellement il ya un plan blanc donc
nous en disent
l'hôpital envisage de faire partir les
patients en métropole pour pouvoir se
faire soigner parce que justement 3 dans
les services centraux à papier par l'aco
vie vous en parliez tout à l'heure où
est-ce qu'on en est justement de la
vaccination est ce qu'il ya des doses
suffisantes pour la martinique alors en
martinique à des doses suffisant nous
avons plusieurs centres de vaccination
et nous avons la chance par dérogation
de pouvoir vacciner avec du fader dans
le cabinet donc nous sommes
approvisionnés donc des cas passion veut
se faire vacciner
nous pouvons vacciner à partir de 12 ans
en cabinet avec le finder bien sûr nous
avons aussi l'astral johnson d'autant
plus que le past and iter est
obligatoire et pour pouvoir à partir du
21 et les motifs impérieux pour venir en
martinique sont réservés aux gens qui ne
sont non vaccinés donc nous aurons ce
soir des annonces des nouvelles annonces
faites par monsieur le préfet nous
allons bien voir quelles mesures vont
être prises
parce que nous sommes notamment il faut
ministre de la santé l'a très bien
exprimé dans votre reportage il faut
jouer collectif et la martinique se doit
de jouer collectif
parce qu'il faut protéger tout le monde
alors on a des manifestations à partir
de 21h anti couvre-feu de manifestations
d'opposition
je pense qu'il faut que la mesure que le
droit de l'anneau vaccination puisse
être mais le droit est rebaptisé de
protéger les autres doit être aussi un
acte citoyen et qui doit être respecté
par tout à chacun est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous attendez des pouvoirs publics
est ce qu'un nouveau confinement serait
utile malgré la forte contestation
visible en martinique
je pense qu'il faut trouver des mesures
qui soient plus souples inde d'un site
est beaucoup plus de monde à se faire
vacciner d'expliquer le pourquoi avec
une communication et bien sûr que les
mesures à partir de 21h de couvre feu
sont déjà efficace il faut limiter il
faut le respecter
donc quand on met des réglementations il
faut que chacun puisse les respecter
mais nous avons une différence par
rapport à l'hexagone
nous sommes une île à l'umih kilomètres
de l'hexagone donc les les forces vives
sont restreintes aussi bien dans le
libéral continua à l'hôpital qu'il faut
que chacun prenne la mesure il faut pas
avoir le match fou du lait pour avoir le
masque sur le nez il faut se faire
baptiser et bien sûr respecter les
gestes barrière merci beaucoup à une
crique ya lieu d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'union régionale des
médecins libéraux de martinique